校長と仏教の出会いについて伺いたいんですけど、つ頃から仏教を学るんですか?
仏教はね、逮捕されてからな、高知書におる間に仏教の勉強したんよね。あそこやったらイラン雑音なしにできるからな。うまく解釈できたと思うよ。あれを暴さなんかに習っとったら未だに仏教は理解できてないと思うけどね。
[音楽]
当時も仏教って言うと大場仏教がメインだと思うんですけど、それはどうやって原子仏教学ばれたんですか?
いやいや、最初コチにいろんな人が差し入れを送ってくんのさ、ほとんどがね、半若心境はない。ほんでこれ何ですか?言ったら読めばわかるって言うんや。読んだって俺は分からんと思う。こじがずらっと書いてあるだけや。申し訳ないけど説明に来てくれってそしたらやあどうのこうの言ってみんなこえへんの?自分が分かってない。
で、半若心教に全てがあると言われとる
もんね。だから犯若者心境を読めわかると
いう風に言われとるやつを読め読めって
言っとるわけ。俺がそういう理解に優れ
とるぞ見たわけじゃないよね。あの悪い
やつを開心させようと思って神経を入れて
くるわけやから。でもしょうがないもんで
な。知り合いに暴さがおったんでその暴さ
に来てもらってな。これようわからへん
言って。だから解説書とかそういうもの
入れてくれんかい?あなたが教えてくれて
もええけど、あなたも分からんでしょう
言ったった。そしたら本当のところはよう
わからんって言うんや。そんなものを読め
読め言うてみんな送り込んでくるわけや
からな。
そん時にね、ついでに言えへん。じゃあ
もう1つ仏教は空を解く宗教でしょ。空の
定義をしてくれ。これはできるでしょう。
暴さなんだけどね。それいやはね、非常に
難しい概念でどうのこ、そんな難しいもの
が世界3大宗教の1つになるはずがないや
ないか。みんな分かったから信者になった
んやで。あなたが分からんだけやないの。
そう言われたら面の大東さんの系統のとこ
やったもんでな。あなたが分からんのは
よう分かった。だけどもそこのお寺が
分からんわけやないやろ。そこのお寺とし
て解釈持ってらっしゃい。1ヶ月こうへん
で。電方売ったったやん。この嘘つき言う
てしたらすっ飛んできてね。いや、確かに
あなたは空の定義を持ってこいと言いまし
たけど、私は持っていくとは言いません
でしたって言うよ。だから嘘はついてない
。それは失礼した言うてで分かるんですか
?言ったらいやあそしたら分かった。
あんたんとこのお寺が分からんのは分かっ
た。本願寺が分からんことはないやろ。
あれだけ大勢の浸透を抱えるほどのとこや
ん。騙して新透作ったわけやないやろ。
本願寺として持ってらっしゃいよ。いやあ
、そんなことを頼めるかな言っとるもんね
。本願寺が逃げたと言うぞ。だったら
ちょっと待ってくれ。じゃあ一ぺって聞い
てきます。からこうへんはな。もうあれ見
た時にね、ま、こりゃいかん思って坊主が
食うが分からんと言ったら許されんよ。そ
やろ。みんなを食うにしようとしとるわけ
やで。大丈夫仏教なんてのは俺が救って
やるということやからみんなを食うにして
やるって言っとんのと一緒やないか。
ところが食うとは何かしら。どうするんや
。おっせだけは取るんやろ。詐欺やないか
。専門家が仏教が分からずにさ、お伏せ
だけは取とるやないか。あげ子の果ては酒
葬式代とってあるいは葬式業者に利用され
ちまって一緒になってあれは市人の衣を
剥ぐようなもんやな。ちょっと正常に戻っ
てくれんかな。
世の中の仏教の本がちょっと宗教職が強めだったり、大腸仏教の解釈が書いてある中で犯境だけあって校長はどうやって原子仏教勉強されたんですか?
原子仏教はまたやり直した最初半若新教呼んでみてね自分の解釈を作んのさそうすると半若心教は大半若教という
1番長いお経やなそれを要約して
200ぼ事にまとめたお経ということになっとるわけよだけどあれ読んでみると
ね、肝心の部分はほんのちょっとしかない
んよ。証券5回空度一切区役それだけで
ええんだ。これだけやで大事なのはで、
それが読めんのはゴ運の意味が違っとるぞ
言って一般に言われとる。ゴ運は普通解説
を読むと肉体と精神ってことになっとるん
や。で、それがどうしたということやね。
で、そうじゃなしに行動の仕方が書いて
あるわけやろ、みんな。ああいうものは。
だからゴ運っていうのは式業
式あるは物を感覚するとか触って触角第六
巻まであるわね。脳は情報処理することや
。脳で行は行動することや。情報処理して
行動して。そうすると式ができる。そう
いう順番で理性ができるぞって言っとるん
。だからその全部が正しければ全部が空で
あれば理性も空になるよという。それ
が運体と精神だって何の意味があるんや。
証券回く同一切やろ。
もう1ついかんのはねど温度の土だ。
そいつを解説読読むとね、散をつけて渡る
という意味にして解釈するんよ。被害へ
渡る意味なんだって言い出すわけ。そんな
ね、胴はね、測るだ。どができたのは1番
最初は席。またのところが幅になってる。
席。昔の宴会の時に床にゴ座を引いたやろ
。あれが席だ。その時に偉い人と偉くない
人は大きさに違いがあるんだ。偉い人は
大きいむろ上に座る。次の人はその次の
大きさのとこに座るという風にこう座って
こうこうこう座っていくわけやな。だから
そのむろを大きさを測らんといかんやろ。
偉くない人の時の大きいの持ってくわけに
いかんから。だからこう手でこうやって
持って幅を見るんだな。だから下にまた
これは手で持って測る温度気温を測るのが
温度というのは測るという意味だ。とそう
すると証見5回空度一切区約全ての区を
法則化できたということなんだからさっき
言ったように正しい区と間違った区がある
わけ白は間違った区だそれ以外の区は
正しい区だからそれ以外の区で行動すれば
区は消えるハックで行動したらいつまで
立っても区は消えない。今の教育がそう
やろ。間違った行動をしとるもんでいつ
まで立っても成果が上がらんから区が消え
ないということが書いてある。
だから正しい理性を作れ。そのためには
全てを食うにすりゃええんやと。ガを捨て
て無がになって物を見るのも考えるのも
行動も全部無がになれば正しい理性が
できるよ。無がになる方法はどうしたら
ええか。そういう風になってくるんだ。
無が本能通りにやれゃ。
理性を捨てればいい。理性は間違っとるん
だ。しょっちゅ間違える。よく野球子供の
頃に野球をやる。うまく弾が取れない玉が
来たらトンネルしちまう。バッと振っても
当たらない。その時にコーチがあんまり
大操とないからね。しっかり玉を見ろって
言うじゃん。そう言われたことないか。弾
を見たら取れるってうん。や、あれ嘘ない
?手のひに集中するんだ。トンネルせずに
取れる。バットを持った手に集中すると
ちゃんと当たるんだ。集中力で理性を消す
ことができるの。だから本能的にやれば
正しい行動なんだから。ちゃんと正しい
行動ができる。え、ゴロは取れる。はい。
考えてみ。グローブを玉筋に持っていく。
取るのは玉に集中したって玉がグローブに
飛び込んできてくれんぞ。動くのは自分に
や。これが正しい行動でこういうことを
やってるとだんだん公然の木が養われるん
だ。だからスポーツでやるのがええよ。
正しい行動は分かるやろ。スポーツやと
うまくいくのが正しい行動だ。社会生活と
か勉強とかではなかなかそれができんやろ
。数学なんかはまだええわね。正しいのは
答えが出てくるから分かる。国語や。あれ
はちょっと分からんやろ。何が正しいのか
先生の方がよう分かってないんやもんね。
だから文化系のものはね、議を行うのが
難しいんや。勉強では。理系あるいは大会
系っていうのは議を行うことが簡単では
ないんやけど分かるんだ。そうすりゃええ
ていうことが分かる。そうすと猛子に書い
てある通り議を行いて生ずるもの正しい
行動ばっかりしてると公然の木が養われて
いくにて遅いてこれを取るものにあらざる
なりこれが公然の木だということをいくら
勉強したって身につくもんかって言っとる
仏教の反論みたいなもんでただ本を読んで
分かったつもりになっとるもんでダメなん
やね。
校長が仏教の半若者新教初めて読んだのが知書の中でっていうおっしゃってたと思うんですけどその時に仏教は科学的で実用的なものだっていうのはすぐ気づかれたんですか?
あれはね無上っていうのあれを知った時や。司法委員って言うんやね。仏教というのはこの
つを満足しとらんといかんぞという。昔はね散方員だったらしいんよ。一切がなかったみたいね。
商業無上処法無が値半弱場の3つらしいん
やけどな。誰かがそれにこれも必要だいう
ことで一切回復実際は一切行業行動変化
変化は区が起こさせる区が変化を起こす区
が行動を起こすこれがいると思ったん
やろうね。だからは大事だよという。
あいつが一切解育だとさっきも最初に言っ
たように全てくであるって言い出すんやね
。だから信じまえということになるわね。
あ、処法無画のところでどの辺が科学的だなっていう風に思われたんですか?
商業務上処法無画だったら科学にしかならんじゃん。科学の定義は再現性やろ。
だから全てが変化せんと結果は出てこん
やろから変化して処法無がその変化の法則
無がっていうのは決まってるがじゃない空
であるだからもう変えることはできないよ
というのが空やな自然の法則として決めた
あるいは神が決めたぞというそういう意味
やね科学でしょさっき言ったこれも言った
やってみろとそうなるからというこれは
これだけの自信は科学じゃないと持てない
誰がやってもそうなるこれが科学だを
なくそと間違ったはなくそうというのが
仏教やね。
[音楽]